فعليا هناك تاهب وانتشار كبير للشرطه
الاسرائيليه حيث اعلنت انها سوف تنشر اكثر
من
22 عنصر من عناصرها كان هناك اغلاقات
كبيره في الطرق رئيسه مؤديه الى البلده
القديمه والمسجد الاقصى هناك ايضا شرطه
الاسرائيليه بنصب حواجز على ابواب المسجد
الاقصى وقامت بتفتيش المصلين اضافه الى
حواجز ايضا بطرق رئيسه مؤديه الى المسجد
الاقصى كانت ايضا قد اطلقت طائره مسيره
تابعه لقواتها تحلق فوق المسجد الاقصى
المبارك على ما يبدو انها تقوم بمراقبه
المصلين عن قرب ايضا كان هناك اعتداء على
المصلين عند باب حطه فجر اليوم حيث منع
الكثير من الشبان الدخول الى المسجد
الاقصى لاداء صلاه الفجر كان هناك ايضا
محاوله للتصدي الشرطه من قبل الشبان كان
هناك هدافات بروح بالدم نفديك يا اقصى لكن
كان هناك اعتداء بشكل يعني كبير
بالضرب المبرح للشبان المقدسيين الاضافه
لذلك كان هناك مظاهرات قد خرجت من مدن
وقرى فلسطينيه في اراضي 48 اين تحدث عن
مظاهرات في الداخل الفلسطيني خرجوا ليله
امس نصره للمسجد الاقصى وتنديدا
بالاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على المصلين كان
هناك ايضا اعتقال لاعداد من الشبان الذين
تظاهروا اما بالنسبه لليوم من المتوقع ان
ايضا يكون هناك جمعه غضب على ما يبدو لان
نحن نتحدث اليوم عن الجمعه الثالثه من شهر
رمضان وهذه الجمعه تحديدا هناك اغلاقات
على الضفه الغربيه بسبب عيد الفصح اي
التسهيلات التي شهدناها الجمعه الاولى
والجمعه الثانيه حيث قامت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه بتسهيل دخول بعض الفلسطينيين
من الضفه الغربيه للصلاه في المسجد الاقصى
ولكن هذه الجمعه نتحدث عن اغلاق شامل
للضفه الغربيه اي ان الحواجز الاسرائيليه
الاسرائيليه سوف تكون مغلقه لن يسمح بدخول
اي فلسطيني من حاملين الهويه الخضراء من
الدخول الى القدس والصلاه في المسجد
الاقصى ربما سوف نشهد هناك اشتباكات على
الحواجز بعد صلاه الظهر لا يوجد هناك
مواقع مؤكده حتى الان ولكن سوف ننتظر ونرى
ان كان هناك فعليا ستكون اشتباكات ننتظر
ايضا ونكون في متابعه معك دائما لنا كلاسي
من القدس كنت معنا مراست العربيه شكرا لك